what isn't in much doubt at least from
the NFL's perspective is that they will
play their games whether it's in front
of fans or no fans dolphins owner Steven
Ross was on CNBC's Squawk Box yesterday
here's Ross expressing his belief that
the NFL will indeed proceed I think
there definitely will be a football
season this year the real question is
will there be fans in this days I think
right now the day we're planning I'm
having fans and staves and again the
plan is to have fans in the stadium the
question is how many fans will be there
I know that at Hard Rock stadium or the
Dolphins play there's been some
contemplation of a reduced capacity but
yeah that's all to be seen they're gonna
play the games at least that's the
message that has consistently come from
the NFL they have never wavered on that
one way or the other they're getting
these games in there's too much money at
stake and they believe that by the time
we get to September the testing will be
at a point where it's it's not easy it's
gonna be a major inconvenience for
everyone to be tested constantly but
there's a way to do it to properly
screen the players the coaches everyone
before they come into a facility and I
think they're gonna have to do it every
day they show up for work to make sure
they're not positive for the coronavirus
and they they believe they're they're
going to get it done Chris and I've I've
seen nothing from the NFL from man from
the teams to suggest any crack any
wavering any suggestion that that this
just isn't gonna work they are
determined to me no you're right they've
been steadfast from the get-go that this
is gonna happen and and you know the the
the big thing to me is really you know
I'm kind of with Stephen Ross and I
think in your boat I'm coming I'm a
believer too and I'm a believer more
that you know I mean it's gonna be this
fall you know whether it kicks off right
away where when the first week of the
season that's supposed to kick off hey I
don't know but I don't think it's gonna
be that far off and then the other thing
that you know I just think that's
interesting in this conversation still
and I know we're gonna talk about this a
little bit but this is to me the big
point of this whole thing is we don't
know where the players really stand yet
and that's to me the last piece of the
puzzle we haven't heard from the masses
of NFL football player
I think you and I both think that
players are want to play and go that you
know because that's what they're born to
do and their careers have a short shelf
life and they got us they got to play
football they want to earn money and
they're young and confident and got
great immune systems but that doesn't
mean every player and every team wants
to play and some players might be scared
of this current circumstances so you
know that's the next part of this phase
that I'd like to hear about it's just
more from the players and you know from
the masses as far as where they stand in
this whole thing and there may be an
disconnect Chris between what the
average Brier wants and what the players
union is going to try to do real sports
with Bryant Gumbel the latest episode
debuted last night and there was a
discussion between Gumbel and three
union Chiefs including NFL PA executive
director de maras Smith and it was also
Michelle Roberts from the NB Players
Association the MLB Players Association
executive director Tony Clark they each
were asked to peg on a scale of one to
ten with ten being absolutely certain
whether or not their sports will play in
2020 and they all were in that range of
six to seven the last one to go was D
Smith and he said probably a six or a
seven lot depends on what happens with
the other sports and to say that we
aren't looking at what's going to have
be happening in basketball baseball I'd
be lying to you if we're not so how
about I go with six seven on a curve now
again it was relative to the to the
faith that was expressed by the other
two executive directors that range of
six to seven out of ten I think that
would surprise some people that the
NFLPA is that low at a time when if you
put the NFL management on a scale of one
to ten it would be 11 Chris to have the
NFLPA
executive director in that range of six
to seven a little jarring and it's a
reminder that there will be things that
have to be negotiated between the league
and the Union before they can have
practice before they can play games
unless the league just takes the
position hey look we're here report for
work or don't and if you don't suffer
the consequences but you've got
contracts to be here
we're saying that the facilities are
open and we're expecting you to show up
now I hope it doesn't come to that I
hope there is cooperation in working out
the terms of a return but there will be
I assume at some point an effort to sit
down and work something out between the
league and the Union and what Dee Smith
said in the program that debuted last
night is a reminder that there may be
some pushback from the Union as it
relates to some of the procedures that
the league may be proposing for
practices and for games yeah well you
know I mean I would think the players
are probably like higher than D Murray
Smith as far as is what they're
expecting a football I would say the
players are around like seven or eight
maybe eight or nine really in most cases
you know but again there are gonna be
pliers in certain locker rooms that are
gonna have concerns and you know yeah
NFL management they could be steadfast
and yeah it's a 11 out of 10 and we're
gonna play and all that that's fine and
dandy you're not the ones out that got
to go out there and sweat and bleed and
hit each other and do all that and you
know and that's all management and all
that owners everybody else they can
still live a pretty protected life here
as they go forward but for NFL football
players you know you gotta get everybody
on the same page here but the full
contact sport and a sport that's got
body pile up son on a play-by-play basis
and germs or always being you know
passed around and things like that as
we've talked about many times so I think
it would be a bad look at the end of tet
fell took that hard stance it was like
facilities open here we go start playing
football we're open for business and I
think that would be very insensitive to
do to the players but you're touching on
something here Chris and this is the
thing that one of us has said over and
over again for the past couple of months
and it ain't me the players want to play
and the players aren't worried about the
virus they want to play the risks that
they take on any given play during a
football game you know when you put the
virus on the scale it's gonna be a lot
lower than some of the other more
immediate physical trauma that they may
endure they're not thinking about it
they're not worried about it and here's
where the union management gets caught
in the middle here because the league
could try to create a wedge between the
rank-and-file and between Union
leadership by taking the position that
look this is what we're gonna do this is
what we proposed and the players are
gonna say let's do it
even if union management is saying let's
take some time and think about it and
talk about it and moments after we
posted the story at Pro Football Talk
comm yesterday with Dee Smith's
estimation that that it's a six or a
seven that the NFL play at all in 2020 a
prominent agent texted me and said does
Dee understand his players want to play
football and earn their livings playing
football and I mean that's the bottom
where you go they wanna bro they want to
make their money they're not gonna give
up their money nobody's gonna pay them
to not play so and they want to play
football this is the same mentality that
infects every labor negotiation between
the league in the Union will they take a
lockout will they go out on strike no
they want to play football and they want
to be paid to play football that is the
way these men are wired especially
because most of them are in their 20s
most are in their early 20s they want to
play football while they can they want
to get paid to play football while they
can and it and if there's resistance
from union management they're gonna be
hearing it from the rank-and-file
players over and over again III think so
you know I would be shocked and again I
you know I'd be interested to know what
the number is around the NFL as far as
players being in favor of going back and
getting things started you know but
again you know the fact that we saw Tom
Brady and you know the school of you
know sweaty but putting you're putting
your towel down there and figure yeah I
know but it just shows you how little
he's scared of the germs and everything
that's going on out in the world and I
think that course that's Tom Brady he's
one of the faces of our league so I
think a lot of people will follow Tom
Brady in that as far as yes like you've
said I don't think the players care that
much I think they want to play football
we know that and stop laughing so I can
finish my point and say focus here okay
hey I saw I'm not the one that said
School of sweaty but I'm thinking of all
the licensing and marketing
opportunities we now have I mean this is
not this is not your Harry Potter school
the school is a different thing
hopefully I'm thinking I'm thinking of
hoodies I'm thinking a hats
I'm thinking of everything we're gonna
make some money off of the school of
sweaty butt but go ahead well yeah you
know I did it but I'm totally distracted
out I didn't know I didn't know Mike you
know who can say you know swamp butt and
got it I just want to discredit anybody
but my point is knowing you know
football players want to play football
and the point is of what you made Mike
these guys are in their 20s and even the
ones that are in their 30s and you have
Brady and Brees you're in their 40s and
you know I would be shocked and they
don't want to play more than just about
anybody in the league but you have a
short shelf life this is you know this
is not hosting Pro Football Talk where
you can go until you know you can't
speak sentences anymore then you as an
NFL football player you know that you
only have a certain time and your life
to go out there make money play the game
you love and at some point and probably
before you're ready it's gonna be cut
off you think oh I'm gonna have a
10-year career well you'll probably have
a five or six year career you know I
mean that's the way it goes in the NFL
so of course these players want to play
this is their chance to capitalize
change their lives change their family's
lives and this is your one Kent well
before you cut the ribbon on the school
of sweaty but I had a thought and this
is a concern that I have now because
back in March there was a spirited fight
among union leadership as to whether or
not they would endorse the current
collective bargaining agreement and in a
weird sort of a way any and all
negotiations and potential friction that
could arise between the league in the
Union as it relates to the terms of a
return to play and practice etcetera
that could become kind of a surrogate
battlefield for those who lost lost you
know and it's it's it's there's a lot of
testosterone involved in this there's a
lot of pride there's a lot of ego right
the people who were pushing against the
CBA lost and this is their Mulligan
potentially to come back chaos right
right and again a win this time we're
gonna show you NFL you RAM that CBA down
our throats we're not accepting your
terms we're gonna push
back on this and we're not we're gonna
fold our arms and we're gonna stop our
feet we're gonna Farrar our brows and
we're gonna tell you to take this job
and shove it and that may be a small
percentage of all players but if it's
enough of the players who are in
leadership positions in the Union now
you got a problem all because you got
guys who still have hard feelings
because they lost back in March well I
never thought about that but I I mean
listen I don't know if I think that
there'll be enough time and a trap it's
when they're right they'll be a few in
the group that it'll certainly want to
ruffle the feathers or make things hard
in this process there's no doubt you
know to me Mike I know we talked about
this a few weeks ago but I and again
listen I know I'm no lawyer and I'm not
a businessman and my brain doesn't work
that way I mean as we've seen here I can
barely speak English but you know the
thing I just would be interested to know
the NFLPA why not start getting some
voting getting some feelings going out
for you know how the players feel right
now about you know the process and what
it will take to make everybody feel
comfortable you're right I mean I don't
think I'm with you I don't think many
players are really gonna care but
there's gonna be a small faction that
either aren't going to be comfortable or
gonna have issues of the CBA and maybe
cause problems whatever it may be but I
wouldn't want to gauge a temperature
test here a little bit you know and the
other thing I'd just bring up to Mike
well go ahead go ahead
No well and this is the first
opportunity I think to get that that
indication of what the temperature is on
the situation Charles Robinson of Yahoo
reported on Tuesday that coaches could
return to team facilities next week we
saw a rash of announcements yesterday
from various states saying hey we're
good to go with professional sports new
jersey which had been shut down new york
made it clear other states doing the
same so coaches could be back next week
which means that all 32 teams will be
able to open their facilities and there
could be a door that opens for mini
camps in June as early as June 15 as
late as June 27 that was the report from
Charles Robinson the NFL quickly said
we're not putting any dates on a return
and then JC Treader the new NFL PA
president tweeted something that I think
crystallizes the
we've been making this isn't just the
nfl's call said Treader our union has
not agreed to any reopening plan and it
reports about coming back to work a
hypothetical you will hear from the
NFLPA
when there are new developments e you
will hear from us in other words we call
the shots well you don't it's a mutual
thing just that that that attitude and
I'm not criticizing and I'm trying to
interpret that attitude that is
reflected in that last sentence you will
hear from us when there are developments
that is a flexing by the Union whether
you try to intended it or not that is a
flexing by him of their muscle and their
will and their position that we got a
seat at the table and we ultimately
control the table because you can't play
the game without us well that it goes
back to what we started the segment with
the owners have been so steadfast and
100% we're going forward we're having
the season it doesn't seem like
anybody's really taking a chance or
taking a moment just to talk to the
players and see where they're at you
know I know we probably know how a few
guys heal but that's a very limited few
we're talking like single digits maybe
double-digit players and of course
there's a there's thousands of players
in football so yeah these are the things
that you know I think got to get figured
out soon to Mike because listen this is
the other thing that I would be worried
about especially if I'm a head coach of
a football team you know I would want a
different training camp this year too
you know with no OTAs probably no
minicams I don't know if I'm Sean Payton
or one of the great coaches in football
I might want my players to come in a few
weeks early this year let's have a few
weeks of kind of like no pads OTAs type
practices before we start getting into
pads making sure everybody's in shape
and mentally ready to go so then when we
do put the pads on we don't take three
steps back because we got people getting
hurt or pulling muscles and doing things
like that and to me that's why the balls
got to get rolling too if we want to
make this machine of the NFL work I
think these are things that are all
going to come up here relatively soon I
don't want them to catch us by surprise
and let me give everyone out there who
may be concerned now that there's a
potential impediment to football
unrelated directly to the virus but a
rising
more from the negotiations between the
league in the union unless it until the
league starts messing with players money
this isn't a huge concern the reason the
MLB Players Association is having a hard
time reaching an agreement on return to
play is because of math of money oh yeah
of how much money the players are gonna
make as long as the players gonna make
their money and the lure of making 100
cents on the dollar Chris that's gonna
be the thing that I think gets the NFLPA
to ultimately agree even if leadership
doesn't want to to whatever terms the
NFL is suggesting because at the end of
the day they're not taking away any of
their money and as long as that's in
play it makes it easier for the NFL to
come
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports